This here is a screenshot of
the Khan Academy unit circle
module.
And the whole point
here is to get
you familiar with the unit
circle definition of trig
functions, which is
just an extension
of the traditional
SOHCAHTOA definition.
But the reason why the
math world did this
is so that we can define the
sine and cosines of angles that
are 90 degrees or more, or
that have actual negative angle
measures.
So let's figure out what
the sine of 275 degrees is.
So we have this dot that's
sitting on a unit circle that
has a circle of radius 1.
And let's hit this
dot to 275 degrees.
Let's make an angle
of 275 degrees
with the positive x-axis.
So let's see, that's 50
degrees, 75 degrees, 90 degrees.
You see the angle
measure right over there.
So 90 degrees, 180
gets us halfway around.
270 gets us at 3/4
of the way around.
So 275 is a little
bit more than that.
And we need to figure out
the sine of 275 degrees.
The unit circle
definition of sine
is that it's the y value of
that angle measure on the unit
circle.
So we've made the angle measure.
We've gone 275 degrees
counterclockwise
from the positive x-axis to get
to this point right over here.
And the y value is
this negative 0.996.
That is the sine of 275 degrees.
Negative 0.996.
If they'd asked for
the cosine, then we
would give the x value of
this point of this dot right
over here.
So the y value is
negative 0.996.
Let's check our answer.
Very good.
Let's do another one.
And we get-- let's see--
sine of negative 55 degrees.
So now we're going to
go below the x-axis.
It's a negative angle.
Negative 55 degrees.
And it's sine once
again, so we want
to look at the
y-coordinate of this point.
So the y-coordinate
is negative 0.819.
Negative 0.819.
Check our answer.
Very good.
Let's keep doing it.
Maybe we'll see a
cosine soon enough.
Sine of 285 degrees.
So 285 degrees, we're
looking right over there.
The sine is the y value.
Negative 0.966.
Let's check our answer.
Let's do another one.
Sine again.
2/3 pi.
So now it's in radians.
We don't see that
little degree sign.
So 2/3 pi.
Let's see-- 2/3 pi
is right over here.
That's the angle in radians
relative to the positive x-axis
going in the
counterclockwise direction.
We care about the
sine which is the y
value of our point sitting
on the unit circle.
0.866.
And one thing that bears
mention is the exact
is square root of 3/2.
And square root of 3/2 if you
were to write it as a decimal
would just continue on forever
without actually repeating.
This is just an approximation.
For the sake of this
module, we really
just want to make you
comfortable with the unit
circle, and maybe
using this tool.
So you really should just type
in this approximate number.
You don't have to
do the exact number
of what square root of 3/2 is.
This is it rounded to
the nearest thousand.
So 0.866.
Let's check our answer.
Let's do another one.
Sine again.
Sine of 15 degrees.
So 15 degrees.
0.259.
I'm going to keep doing
this until I get a cosine.
So let's do it again-- cosine!
Very good.
2 pi.
2 pi radians.
Well 2 pi is completely going
around the unit circle once.
So let's go all the
way around, and we
see that we get back to
where we were before.
We've gone around
to 2 pi radians.
We're back to where
we were before.
The cosine is the x
value of that point.
So the x value of
that point is 1.
The x value of the point is 1.
If we wanted the
sine of 2 pi, then we
would get 0 because we have
no y value right over here.
We're at the x-axis.
Let's check our answer.
Let's do one.
Maybe we'll see another cosine.
There we go.
Another cosine.
Cosine of 112 pi.
So that's just going
to be a little-- let's
see, 1/35, 1/18, 1/12.
Cosine.
We want the x value,
not the y value.
The x value is 0.966.
So 0.966.
Check our answer.
And we are done.